[Music]
oh
e
[Music]
the following is a presentation of the
St Louis chess
club players from 14 Nations converge in
St Louis as you uschess champs.com
presents the third annual spring chess
[Music]
classic hello chess fans and welcome
back to St Louis for round two of the
spring chess classic whoa there we go
hello my name is Ben Simon joined by
Grandmaster Aman Hamilton and the lights
are on we are ready to go here under the
beautiful kingside Diner it's a snowy
day in St Louis but the players are
upstairs in the tournament Hall already
they made it that's that's good I wonder
if anybody was late today I don't know
uh I think Hansen cut it close but uh
you know respectably on time as a
Canadian always is always is always is
anyway we are underway in this event
let's take a look at our standing so far
after only one round this is in the
Masters division we have 10 players
representing seven different federations
here in this field four games were
decisive out of five and I think this is
going to be typical of the action you're
going to see in an event like this where
we don't exactly have the World Elite
but you will see a lot of you'll see
enough blunders I guess to make it
really entertaining well I think we saw
that and most notably the the result
that came after our broadcast finish was
actually Ivan chuk lost that position to
to vuan niobian which has Ivan chuk
there at the bottom of the table so
he'll definitely be looking to back
after that that result there and let's
glance over at our parent or our
standings for the B
group with byin sheet uh in the lead
along with Nicholas theodoro uh and then
three games were drawn in this field
yesterday y all right we invite you to
join us all across social media remember
we do have the YouTube chat open today
we'll be taking your questions if you
have anything thoughtful and also uh be
sure to subscribe to us on YouTube and
check out the action at uschess
champs.com we have the live boards on
uschess champs.com so if we don't happen
to be covering the game live that you
want to see right now you can go take a
look at it
yourself all right here are the rules
for this event the regulations if you
will we have two 10 player round Robbins
the time control is 90 minutes for the
first 40 moves and there is 30 minutes
added on after that for the remainder of
the game because of a 30- second
increment for move number one all the
players have to keep taking notation and
we are unlikely to actually see anybody
flag in this event although technically
I think one game flagged yesterday uh
was it Jin's opponent yes uh it was uh
Sten gson from Iceland right he was
losing anyway he was losing anyway but
uh you know he he decided to let the
time run out so that he could uh
disprove the statement that you just
said y there you go and there is a 30
move draw rule in effect the players
cannot agree to any draw offer uh before
the 30th move of black and here's the
schedule for this event it's pretty easy
to remember we start every day the game
start at 1 p.m. central Time and we are
on the Air 2 and 1 half hours after the
opening bell so 3:30 p.m. every day
except for the final
day all right let's take a look at our
pairings for group a these games are
already happening and they're all in
progress at uschess champs.com KMJ
versus Eric Hansen Ray Robson versus
elen mnik these two have played before
actually uh all draws in recent years
three draws at the spice cups and then
13 years ago it was nnick who got the
upper hand but that was in a Under 12
event so times have changed there's not
much uh similar now do you think they
remember that you know like is is they
still hurting 13 right yeah it's like I
think he got me all those years ago but
so this is the fifth classic classical
game they've ever played uh VAR toan and
Benjamin Bach have played one time
before that was a draw actually at the
Summer Classic last year right Jeffrey
Jeong versus vasilia ivanchuk and then
our key matchup of the day Liam Lee
versus Arian tari both Victors from
yesterday and we'll see if anybody can
go two for two after today and let's uh
see where we are in that game thus far
yeah um so we're just going to jump
right into this one and and actually Ben
it's uh you know it's it's already
rumbling the position is rumbling just
like our studio the environment is
turbulent here and uh you know really
just wanted to set the mood for the game
um because this one uh I see already
just noticeable time Advantage for um
lukang lien and uh if we just take a
quick look at the last couple moves to
sort of see how we got here um this was
a sicilian started off as a sicilian but
now um I think the last couple moves
really
showed this G5 move I start to get maybe
a little nervous for forari but after e
takes F4 he's saying that if uh if white
takes back um Pawn takes then you know
maybe he would think about Pawn takes
here and the question is really in these
types of positions if that black Bishop
can establish itself on E5 and maybe the
king gets out to
G7 you know is is white actually proving
anything here because the bishop on G2
when the bishop goes to E5 is not going
to be good what's scary is if white has
time for maybe some sort of aggressive
move like E5 and and really opening up
this diagonal um you know maybe sinking
a knight in on the F6 sare and maybe
this this could get uh this could get a
little dicey so perhaps he's uh he's
concerned about something like like this
as we see G takes F4 plate on the board
right now now you can see the players on
on your screen there tari is uh you know
uh he's got about half the time on the
clock and players are on move 29 though
so probably not the most uh concerning
time difference uh that that we've seen
open up just yet um but yeah after G
takes F4 I imagine it would be Pawn
takes uh the only other option is Bishop
uh G7 here and and yeah Bishop G7 could
be played but I think we're going to see
Pawn takes uh Ben and actually that's on
the board already so I think we're
probably going to get that line um Pawn
takes Bishop G7 and I don't know if
we'll see E5 or not but I think that's
the critical one to to consider here
takes and uh if not E5 I I have a
feeling that black can can sort of put
the bishop there and say and say that uh
you know you're blockading on the dark
squares strong Knight on C5 strong
Bishop on E5 this queen can swing over
the king can get off the H file and uh
not not actually so so sure in this
position for white unless there's that
that tactical shot like E5 um for white
opening things up so I think I think
that's what uh L kuang is uh is mainly
contemplating here does Liam Le's move
that you proposed E5 does that lose a
pawn somewhere in there yep it
definitely does uh I'm trying to justify
so really my opinion is that uh he's
probably thinking about E5 even in the
current position because uh I just have
a feeling that if a bishop gets the E5
for black it's actually maybe black who
who's kind of comfortable and uh just
thinking from L Wang's perspective I
don't know if you can allow that I don't
know if you can allow Bishop E5 so I'm
mainly suggesting E5 because I'm looking
at a bishop on E5 and I'm I'm wondering
if black is is even fighting for more
than just equality there um now very
very well could be you still have uh was
like Bishop H3 Queen H3 but uh you know
it actually starts to look decently
comfortable there for um for black Maybe
maybe Knight F6 is an idea as well but
you know in all these positions starts
to open up a little bit E5 so so I I
think we just need to prevent E5 in some
way for uh sorry prevent Bishop E5 by
black in some way so whether that's
playing E5 ourselves which does jettison
a pawn or whether it's playing Knight F6
and uh and blocking the Bishop from from
actually getting there so you have E5
let's say Rook takes
E5 maybe I would take take here first
takes and you know this is me just
trying to force force things in of
course tactically this may may just be
unsound um you know the queen has to
move now and black probably has time to
defend the bishop which I'm attacking
here as well as get out of this with
something like Queen G7 maybe or queen
B8 I feel like uh I feel like black is
probably doing okay
um I think he can can survive here but
yeah Bishop E5 looks uh looks really
solid for forari if he can uh if he can
achieve that here all right well let's
uh move on to our next field oh before
we do that I got to tell you in our
YouTube chat
mdm2 uh is very appreciative he says I
like yaser's new haircut yaser's new
haircut yeah that I think I think he's
mistaking is it a new haircut or a new
hair color because a new haircut would
imply that uh yaser's natural state is
purple hair like the purple hair isn't
weird it's just I like the way the
purple hair is cut today okay um so I
mean that's I definitely appreciate that
comment being uh being compared to
Yasser um maybe I'll suggest purple hair
to him next time I see him we're going
to deconstruct every single comment you
guys make so make them good let's take a
look at our field and our standings or
our pairings rather for Group B these
games are going on right now at usess
champs.com he Haden Stein Grimson versus
Alexi s
Alexander Mista versus Nicholas theodoro
Dennis Kadri versus Sergey aronberg
Christian carilla versus Gregory
kaidanov and our key matchup to watch
this round byin Shi who we talked to
yesterday against the former winter uh
classic Champion Andre barish pitz let's
take a glance at the progress of this
matchup yeah we've got this game uh
underway here and and right off the bat
you can uh you can sort of see that the
uh the bgroup uh B is afforded much
better lighting than the a group I think
that's what we need to focus on here uh
the the other guys looked like they were
in a Canadian Igloo uh quite frankly but
but this looks fantastic well we need to
address this right so so there is no
professional lighting right now up in
the tournament Hall one side of the room
has Windows the other side does not have
Windows and then there's also the
adjustment of our robotic cameras up
there but really lighting it let's let's
take take the lighting at face value
here you would much rather be playing on
this table than like one of the other
tables we've looking at right and and I
think uh byen she's very comfortable in
the B group here that that you know
there's a halfway point in the room
where it just transitions into that that
a group you know you maybe he had the
option he's strong enough maybe to play
but he's like no I'll take first spot in
the B group yeah I like I like it over
there um but yeah we did talk to to byin
on the broadcast yesterday who took us
through his his first round win which
was uh which was nice of him and he
actually gets um he gets I'm not
mistaken he gets the white pieces uh
twice to start off in the tournament so
uh he's going to try to use them to the
maximum here and what we've got is a
position of opposite color Bishops which
uh I should just point out initially
does not actually uh mean that it's just
a draw or dead equal or anything like
that um it very well could be but not
just because of the Bishops um in these
positions white is usually favored
slightly
uh just because the King has a really
nice home on
F2 and uh you know Black's pawns being
on C4 and A6 are are noticeably weaker
than whites on B2 and A2 just because
they're
disconnected this bishop in an end game
would sit very nicely on C3 um but make
no mistake uh the the move Queen takes
A6 is is going to be what's really
critical uh here in this position and I
think that he's actually played it
that's what just appeared on the board
there
yeah so if we just take a look at the
last couple moves um this came from a a
Catalan um and you often get these
opposite Bishop positions takes takes
and after Rook D1 and queen takes A6 we
have a temporary situation where um
white is up a pawn and if you sort of
look forward to an end game imagine the
Queens are traded uh this outside a pawn
is going to be uh it's going to be very
dangerous Ben so something to be uh very
very conscious of the don't let that
pawn sneak up too far cuz you can
imagine that pawn getting all the way to
A7 defended by the bishop I mean white
would essentially be winning in in in
that case so uh we've got this position
Queen takes A6 uh what is barsh poet's
planning here because it feels like he
needs a move uh C3 I'm not sure if
that's his intention he's played it on
the board just now he needs a move
because there's no Rook A8 Rook B8
making any serious threats on the white
queenside pawns C3 has been played the
idea that if
takes Queen takes um let's say move like
King F2 for example and uh I think no
question that uh byin is uh he's playing
for the win here is the advantage
significant not really it's one Pawn but
uh although you've got opposite Bishops
on the board like I've been saying
that's an outside pass pawn and uh
White's got all to play for uh here I
think that barish bulletz is is just
trying to sort of liquidate here if he
could trade the queens and the Rooks
opposite Bishop end game then I think
he's he's got great chances for a draw
um but here I think they there's still
still a lot to play for for white that
extra Pawn is you know it's no joke and
B has uh taken on C3 I mean do you think
that it's worth it though for Andre to
play C3 just because it draws the
connected pawns away from each other
yeah and also just generally if you
trade trade trade you're going to be
better off in the end game you just
liquidate um because if you have that
one extra Pawn but no other pawns on the
board would just be a draw so the closer
you get I guess to to full liquidation
would be would be preferred so yeah C3
makes total sense but at the end of the
day you're not winning that a pawn by
force and if you're not winning it by
force you're you know you're going to
have to do some suffering some some
defensive work ahead um for black here
in in this position so really byin she
is not going to lose the game he has a
chance to win the game and there's not
much more you can uh really hope for
with the white pieces so playing such a
strong event so I feel like he'll be
relatively satisfied here we have our
first result of the day in the a group
Jeffrey Jong and Vil ivanchuk have
drawn um so let's we will get to that in
just a moment I think I overheard that
we have someone coming in for an
interview I wasn't sure who that was
great uh but but yeah it's going to be a
really fun day um before we take a look
at this uh and just start going around
the horn I want to take you to the prize
funds if we have them there's a lot to
fight for in this tournament you know
this is uh St Louis it's chess Heaven
group a $6,000 is your grand prize and
in group b not too shabby itself $4,000
your grand prize a total prize fund of
36k not too bad very generous prize fund
as Karina NSA would say and it's uh the
my favorite part about it is that you
you leave with money no matter where you
finish yes so you get it's that good
feeling like you're you're being respect
you're being paid for your work no
matter what and uh I I think that's one
of the best ways to to keep the players
comfortable you don't feel like you're
ever going home empty-handed so to speak
oh and uh it looks like we have a late
relay on uh on Group B Because heeden
Stein Grimson has defeated his opponent
Alexis sokin the FM and we will have
Stein Grimson in for an interview so
let's take a look at a game and we'll
get him in here for that uh for that
talk okay
that's great we'll get him in here
always nice to get people in for the uh
the interviews I feel like I barely got
a a chance to check that one as well
there's a few games I mean when you when
you start the broadcast into the round
obviously there's a there there's a
chance that that games can simply finish
before you uh even really get a a chance
to uh take a look at them so that's uh
basically what's happened here and uh be
nice to to have him in here to take us
through the game this game on your
screen right now is um the game between
Jeffrey Jong and vasil ivanchuk and this
game was just agreed to a draw and I
have to say this is a rather interesting
opening by vook here he plays D6 and
just immediately Bishop G4 and
E6 very very
um very very interesting opening from
ivanchuk he's just looking to trade
pieces he castles long and and uh I
wonder if they they probably repeated
here with Queen E4 and Bishop D3 did
they yeah yeah Bishop D3 Queen D5 Bishop
C4 Queen E4 and so they just uh just
repeated moves there but yeah that's
actually a pretty interesting opening
from from ivanchuk there coming off a
loss in the first round D6 Bishop G4 I'm
not not too used to this but actually
kind of has shades of like a uh
scandinav
where you cast along and there's so much
pressure on on the D4 Pawn that okay if
white plays C4 which is what what he did
in the game D4 is not an easy pawn to
maintain I mean you're you have easy
moves like uh Bishop to F6 and of course
you always have Bishop takes
F3
um taking here and and D4 is weak so
they actually agreed to a draw here and
uh yeah that was the game between
Jeffrey J and Vil ivanchuk but uh we're
going to take a look at uh the game
between uh heden Stein gson and Alexis
soken and we are nice enough to be
joined by uh steinon himself hello hi
thanks for joining the broadcast here uh
congrats on the on the win um and yeah
we' love it if you'd uh you know sort of
take us through the the game and and how
developed right from right from the
start
here yeah so it was a NSU indan and I
played this line with E3
and and Castle T to right I guess rookie
eight is is fairly uh fairly topical now
yeah yeah I had that game actually
against Grand sometime ago yes where he
also played rookie eight and actually
came up with some interesting novelty so
I played A3 on Bishop f8 did you play um
the same way again so what was the no
this knight3 move was something def was
it E4 uh no I think I played probably D3
right and okay D5
yeah and now I played Bishop E2 which is
I think is a rather rarely play move
uhhuh and I actually don't I think his
next move is an inaccuracy DC4 yeah and
um because black can play maybe what C5
yeah black has actually many ways here
it's sort of you know just the position
yeah it's just the position at the end
of the day but okay he took C4 yeah and
now it's important that I Castle right
because if I take back then he's going
to play C5 yeah and now if I take then
he takes on D1 and I can't to I want to
take back with the Rook right yeah Absol
and also I not really allow him to
change on D4 because he's going to play
Knight B D7 and B6 yeah let's very
quickly and then my
knight well yeah you may be a bit Yeah
so that this play done G3 so he's going
to play Knight B D7 probably and Knight
B6 yeah and it's probably going to be
fine yeah looks like a easy position
yeah so I think it was good to Castle
and I think that's actually the reason
why it was not so good to take on four
mhm and okay now he already is in a
little trouble
because okay he plays C5 is a sort of
natural move right but we see the big
difference between castling right it's
now that same line he somehow plays
something more passive then there is
also always some E4 E5 in the position
Knight D7 yeah then probability of D4
right and um yes okay he plays C5 yep
and I take on
C5 and he took with bishop and I take on
C4 right and I think this is actually
quite a pleasant position yep okay now
he played Knight
bd7 and okay I played
B4 um if I play Knight E4 then he
probably takes and plays Knight
E5 that's interesting move and uh I
think I don't have anything special here
right right and pieces are trading yeah
and now my Tempo count of only3 is maybe
not so relevant because the bishop is
going to retreat anyway right so okay I
played
B4 and okay I I actually expected him
somehow to play Bishop f8 but he went
Bishop
E7 right and okay Bishop B2 again there
is always this if I play Knight D4 he
can probably take and play Knight D5
again takes E5 like this so I play
Bishop B2 and now he plays A5 which is
kind of a critical move right otherwise
he is sort of accepting to be yeah the
bishop is kind of an issue at this point
right so this is the sort of yeah either
he has to accept being worse or try this
okay now it's a little now I took on A5
who kind of has
some kind of pluses and minuses yeah
pluses and minuses yeah and okay he took
with a rook so of I think normal and
Knight
B5 and okay I'm not sure what the
computer says so I don't know yeah so
well me neither so let yeah okay we're
on the same page so night B6 kind of
rather forcing P
D3 and P D6
and queen
E2 and now he surprised me a bit I
thought he
might well he can you know he played
Knight F D5 right um maybe it's possible
to play Knight D4 A4 first and then
Knight with Knight to D5 he would go
Bishop um yeah well it's kind of
different options Maybe can also Play
Bishop
E5 and um
yeah and uh yeah this is kind of maybe
not so this one's also yeah yeah and now
maybe Knight D5 I actually expected this
or maybe he can also try something just
to play like instead of Knight A4 just
the other Knight to D5 try to somehow
this just play sort of solidly mhm but
okay this Knight fd5 was a little risky
maybe well because of your your next
move especially yeah so now he kind of
has a positional threat to play Knight
A4 and if I move the bishop to play
Knight C5 and if I play Bishop C4 then
maybe if everything goes well the other
Knight to B6 and sort of capture my
light Square Bishop right but I have
some I can do
something like if it was his move again
yeah but okay I play Knight H5 this is
an interesting
move and I think he has to play
G6 with itate and now I play
E4 and now I actually expected Knight
A4 and I thought I don't have anything
better than to take on D5 and I takes B2
and queen takes B2 he takes my knight on
H5 and I take on E6 mhm and okay maybe
I'm a bit better here but it's not the
end of the world for him right he still
got that dark SP Bishop right he can
take maybe with Bishop on E6 or or even
maybe play Bishop F6 right and maybe I
play something like Queen yeah or I I
can play Maybe Rook 8 D1 here and okay I
thought I was is a bit better but it's
not like uh he is still sort of fighting
yeah it's not the end of the game at all
right so I I thought he would do this so
he surprised me a lot with the move he
played the KN C7 moovie yeah because
that just sort of gives me sort of free
atanes a little bit well it's just such
a forcing continuation and maybe just
for the
viewers we can like if he takes my
knight on
H5 instead of the Knight yes here and
then I can take his Knight on
D5 and if he captures back mhm then at
least pishop by H7 is a move right and
he obviously cannot take back he then I
take on H5 and there's a Checkmate on h8
yeah so okay but okay he can play King
f8 but his King is weak and you know
it's s of one
one uh yeah complely one-sided at this
point yeah and I hadn't really looked
whether I have some Force to win but but
yeah these types of positions you you
know you get there and think right think
yeah and okay but he played Knight C7
which is kind of surprised me and okay
now I just take on C7 yeah Queen takes
and Knight F6 P takes and P takes and
now I obviously am better yes and I
think maybe he has to play Queen F4
four uh because if he plays Rook H5 then
probably I just play F4 mhm and okay
here I can I can play any move pretty
much some I'm always yeah I mean this
bishop is just a long term maybe Bish
D4 and uh the Knight doesn't have any
squares The Rook is yeah so this is just
uh yeah kind of clear What's Happening
Here Right but he actually plun he
played E5 yeah is unfortun now I can't
to win in one
move yeah so and then he rested right so
yeah so I think it was a bit imprecise
to take on C4 and then maybe this Knight
F D5 was a little at least risky move
mhm but it seemed even uh in this game
there were a lot of moments where he
maybe could have put up some resistance
yeah definitely yeah I don't know it was
maybe 23 moves or something so right
kind of yeah at the end saying yeah yeah
no question about it but uh I mean
you'll you'll take the mistakes you
you'll take because I mean you were you
were pretty much seem to be in in
control maybe since the the DC4 yeah I I
I think so I I don't know really but uh
that's my impression right right yeah so
I mean it's it's obviously good to to
get a win win and uh I mean you're
coming here from from Iceland did you
come just from from Iceland directly
well I actually live here in the US you
live here now okay so I I didn't but I
was recently in Iceland and I am quite
often in Iceland right but uh this time
I just uh yeah kind of a little shorter
flight yeah shorter flight I'll be going
to Iceland for the raiki Vic open so
right then I'll be going there so you
are warming up with the snow yes exactly
getting used this snow but we have
enough of that up in Canada so I'm used
to it but um yeah this is obviously a
great result for you thanks for taking
us through the game and obviously wish
you the best of luck in in the rest of
the rounds thank you thanks it's uh
Hayden Stein Grimson from Iceland with
his victory against Alexi sorin from uh
Russia and obviously that is a uh pretty
quick game 23 moves and uh just Invasion
on the dark square is in the final
position uh e
I think was a final blender from from
his opponent there but um I think
without the move E5 as as we were
discussing in the analysis here it would
uh it would still be completely winning
for white as as the dark squares and
especially that dark Square Bishop on F6
uh probably just too much to handle for
um for black there so uh that's one of
the quickest victories actually of the
tournament so far and uh and that means
he is uh is right back in the tournament
in the B group because there were a lot
of draws in in the B group so uh any win
is it's going to you know suddenly just
catapult you to the top of the top of
the table yeah absolutely and and it's
funny cuz they he's outside he's outside
ready for the interview the the dgt
board hadn't registered yet we're like
what um so let's let's take a look at
some of the other games here I want to
look at the Webster rivalry in group a
Ray Robson versus Elia nnick nnick still
goes to Webster he's still on the
Webster uh t team led by Susan pulgar
and Ray Robson is a graduate and uh
these two have played four times before
uh the last decisive Victory though was
way back in 2006 ancient history but it
looks like black is got the edge here in
this particular matchup Ilia Nik looks
like he's going to uh improve his
lifetime score yeah so these guys are
are right into it here and I mean the if
I'm not mistaken that time for Ray
Robson is not looking too good already
down to just over a minute um the only
thing that uh that I can say about this
position is that it looks like nnick is
is about to win on the spot um handshake
in E second yeah because we just see
this move Knight H4 King G3 I mean he's
getting mated on G2 and uh he's probably
going to play Queen takes G2 King takes
H4 Queen takes F2 played and you can
just sort of see the the
the dynamic of the position is that uh
White is going to be left with his two
Rooks I think he's I mean he's not happy
but the position obviously it looks
completely losing but at the very least
black can take that bishop and bring the
queen back to G5 and you have two extra
pawns the nice thing about two extra
pawns is if you only had one extra Pawn
white always has this idea of bringing
the Rook down and then maybe taking the
pawn sacking for the queen but because
of that extra Pawn on D5 it's just not
possible right um so so at the very
least he can take that Bishop I don't
know whether there's you know even Queen
D4 might be uh might be a
move I haven't uh haven't thought about
about this like trying to get some
checks uh and win a rook city right yeah
so I don't know if we can win a rook um
by somehow you know like check check but
the king king goes to F5 there so I'm
trying to uh trying to actually win more
material than uh than just that but
we'll see what uh what nishna can do
here but with the black pieces the time
really tells the tale you almost don't
have to look at the evaluation of
position just yep he's up like 30
minutes on the clock down to a minute is
Ray Robson and uh this is not looking
good for for white the only thing white
has in this position is that uh
absolutely pinned G Pawn I don't think
there's really any way to unpin that
because I keep wanting to push the G
pawn and cut off some squares right May
King H4 and try to get some cheeky
Checkmate in yeah has going for him well
I think right now if uh King H4 that
would essentially be uh repeating right
because so he is probably going to go
King H4 um and after King H4 I'm just
trying to see if there's anything that
he might want to do other than than
Queen back to F2 but I mean queen takes
D2 is the idea and why why is the king
want to be on H4 well if I play Rook E7
now with the same idea now we've got
check ma in one so he's forced the king
back to the side just a little
uh little subtlety there and now because
you can't move the Rook Queen F4 is a
threat I mean this is on the board by
the way Queen F4 is game-winning threat
Queen G5 is a threat if you move the
Rook Queen D4 is a threat and I mean you
just can't you just can't cover
everything Ben that this is just
completely over um so it's a nice little
subtlety there if the King was still on
G4 in this position white could play
Rook E7 and still fight the Rooks
connect and threatening G7 but now
rookie s loses on the spot and uh I
think Ray is probably going to resign um
I don't see uh a good move for white to
stay in the game here Rook to
F5 maybe that's one
move okay so it's five moves until time
control do you think he'll try to push
out five moves and then give it a think
oh he could def as long as he finds a
move here that doesn't lose a rook he's
going to play it um he's not going to
resign just because it's queen against
two Rooks but he he'll he'll resign if
he doesn't see a move or if he wants to
play what did he play Rook E7 okay so he
played Rook E7 and his idea is Queen F4
King H5 now you can imagine if this is
what you're playing you're really living
on the edge here I think there's just a
force win Queen F4 check King here and I
think Queen
G3 uh I think this should be Force
win because I'm
threatening I'm threatening this
which is going to be Checkmate in order
to protect that if you go Rook here then
that's a Checkmate on G5 and if you move
your Pawn I have a choice between
checkmates here Queen F3 or queen G6 so
I think that that's probably good enough
here is uh just Queen F4 and queen G3
maybe there's even another option but
you know when you see a good uh a good
continuation you don't need a second one
right you don't need a second one so I
think we're going to see Queen G3 here
by nishnick and that should be a
resignation uh from from Robson here as
we're still still looking for move 40
what do he play
D4 play D4 I wonder
why when when you see this Ben this is
when you start to go do some
introspection what did I miss I must
have missed
something right like like
uh this just looks like
checkm
this just looks like Checkmate but okay
you know again when when you when you
got your dessert in front of you it
doesn't matter if you eat it with a fork
or a knife m 2 is the same as M three in
practice you know um but okay completely
winning so we we definitely say there's
just no chance for Ray robs in there
pretty much in zwang I mean queen G3
number of ways to win so Elan isik is uh
is going to win that game with with the
black pieces and and be off to a great
start in uh in this tournament but Ry
actually won his game from yesterday
against km janov so uh he's uh he's
still doing doing just fine it's still
really anybody's tournament you know
there's no one's really Rising above yet
right nnick though is the incumbent
World open champion and he wanted
everybody to know that after he won the
World open he came here at the club and
he was like hey you want to talk to me I
won the World open we're like oh well
how about that that's pretty awesome
there it is there's the handshake
there's the handshake and I Nik playing
for Ukraine and Webster University wins
against his former teammate at Webster
Ray
Robson so we'll probably be able to talk
to Ilia nnick down here in the studio
yeah hopefully that looks like a nice um
that looks like a nice game definitely a
big win for for him now I want to jump
over to Group B before we get Ilia
because Christian Cilla is going down it
looks like he's in a lot of trouble in
his game against Gregory kaidanov the US
champion Ship Legend let's take a look
at that Whoa We got some I mean there
used to be there used to be a whole Pawn
uh protection layer in front of that
white king what what happened Ben well
it's times have changed I don't see
anything that resembles that anymore
right it used to be okay here we go back
here move 21 that's where you know times
were normal okay move 21 each Pawn just
ate away and if we uh if we kind of
think about this opening not to go
through the whole game but just um kind
of funny we actually see a a reverse
position and I always find these rather
interesting because it's like um
basically this is a grinfeld you know
from the other side so usually white has
this Pawn Center and I always find these
reverse openings funny because it's like
well if it's if it's like still you know
kind of a tense opening you know back
and forth when white plays it how is it
even playable with black you're just
down a move you know what I mean it's
like that always confuses me about these
these reversed open
um because really you're you're just
down one move and uh they are playable
though but it's just a fun funny thing
to think about um because we see Cilla
doing a something that you don't usually
see black to from from the other side
and the reason he's doing it is because
he's got that extra move so and you're
talking about bring bringing the bishop
back to2 um mostly bringing this Knight
to B3 like that just very quickly
because normally we would actually have
black in this case well white when it's
reversed just be like developing that
Bishop much quicker having an extra move
getting castled and you know it' be kind
of uh crazy for black to be doing this
maneuver so it's really something that I
think we're seeing as a product of just
having that extra Tempo um and it means
that the position we got was a little
unique so white won the bishop pair and
then it's funny these next two moves you
see Bishop E1 Bishop H3 Bishop H1 so
he's keeping the Bishops he's he's
respecting the Bishops but uh because
he's he's gone backwards with the pieces
so much uh we look at how black played
the position he just said okay H5 H4 and
while white is trying to do stuff like
Rook C3 Rook A3 you know trying to take
some pawns here black is saying go right
ahead um I'm going for the attack and
yeah he goes and takes that A7 Pawn but
now I mean we're looking at this
position Queen D4 has just been played I
think we just saw a move from uh from
kaidanov there what did he play I mean
it shouldn't be surprised yeah Knight G3
and I mean it's got to be over right I I
think it's just completely over I mean
obviously if you take here uh takes King
to H1 there's a nice move here I mean
you're going to find tactics Ben when
the position looks like that but okay
here's one of them Rook takes E2
overworked Bishop if I take that that's
Queen G2 mate uh if Rook G1 to cover the
mate I have Queen H2 mate and that King
is stuck in the corner there so um
that's one one way to lose if you take
that Knight but at this point the only
other moves are moving your King right
you got to get out of this uh this
discovered check so he played the move
King H2 so he's threatening the bishop
he's threatening the Knight that is
technically a double attack but it won't
be surprising to me uh if a move like
Knight E2 is just completely winning
here if you take it I take with check if
you go win my my piece this is not a not
a position that I've necessarily
calculated but okay it's not
not something that's going to surprise
me if it's winning right that you're
always going to find a way when the
position has gone the way that it has
here so Knight takes E2 looks uh looks
good
enough um I wonder if he's going to play
that or or keep thinking here because he
has he has maybe other ways to play um
obviously Knight F5 is a is a move but
Knight E2 just seems Seems so good so I
think he's just I think he's just
double- checking here but there are
probably a lot of good moves that win
once again it's just a question of you
know choosing choosing how you want to
win the count is going down to the
oldest player in either field Gregory
kaidanov you know killa I'm sure wanted
a good good showing in this event
because of the big news recently of
course he was in the Press I don't know
if you saw this what was he in the Press
not for anything bad not for anything
bad but he is starting the first ever
missou chess club the missou chess team
rather right and they're going to be
competing on I mean the grandest stage
of college chess I mean we in recent
years we've seen uh so many
good collegiate teams of course Webster
and slooh and lyen wood in the past um
and now Columbia Missouri for those of
you not around here is about two hours
west of St Louis so it's not St Louis uh
expanding all across the state and uh
you know this is just going to be a
windfall around the the Midwest so right
really neat stuff I think slooh was
another sort of recent Edition semi-
recent right with Alejandro Ramirez
Alejandro Ramirez um so this is another
uh program that's you know going to
probably establish itself as as one of
the top programs around here so just
another another one into the The
Cauldron this is going to be a lot of
competition yeah and you know after
college these are this is the future of
the US chess you know so very exciting
stuff U unfortunate though for Killa
today as he looks to uh have a loss
quite imminently yeah this looks like uh
Cilla is going to be going down here as
kaidanov is just putting the uh
finishing touches on this game um what
other games caught your eye there Ben
because I want to stay around Group B
right that looks like some fireworks
happening there yeah yeah yeah um Al
Alexander Mista versus the Greek
Nicholas theodoro uh let's take a look
at that game yeah Mista with the
advantage here yeah we're looking at uh
we have to say a very abnormal position
honestly um and uh well yeah yeah yeah
yeah you know you say that uh Mista has
the advantage but if if yeah if he finds
one move I I must I must confess this
was uh an a statement based on the
engine bar I saw but yeah it's not too
clear is it well to most people Mista is
losing a piece so he's losing that
Bishop on C1 by force and the the reason
that the position remains uh probably
even playable is because white is going
to take this Pawn on A5 and this a pawn
strangely enough is actually really hard
to stop so so uh in this position it's
white to play let's say okay let's say
King takes A5 just to look
um Bishop B2 to try to save uh save the
piece there's Knight takes
B2 Knight takes C3 and at the very very
least we could sacrifice the Knight for
the pawn and and survive here but uh I
imagine that black is actually winning
this um because of something like maybe
Knight D5 uh and later we'll put the
Knight on B six and so you let this Pawn
go all the way here you put the Knight
there and then you bring your king over
and take that pawn so actually black has
has probably just winning in this
position um so that's why white is not
playing Bishop B2 but if you can't play
Bishop B2 then you have to understand
with the King on a light square there's
no like sneaky checks there's no way to
just throw that Bishop out there and try
to win a rook with a discovered check uh
you're losing that Bishop no matter what
so um I imagine that uh we're going to
have to go for some sort of either like
C4 move or King takes A5 um but Knight
D3 played if I just go back a little bit
in this game I can show you guys how we
got here because it probably gives a
little bit more perspective um on why
maybe this position is good for white
because here White's actually up two
pawns it just looks funny because
they're both
doubled um and in exchange for that
Black's counterplay is he's pinning this
bishop to the rook and that was uh the
only way that he was basically staying
in the game otherwise down two pawns
should be should be completely winning
so we see the king the white king is the
only piece that can move when you're
stuck in a pin like that and yeah he's
made it all the way up to all the way up
to
A5 Knight D3 and yeah I imagine we're
we're going to see King A5 I mean the
actual lines not sure how they go takes
I don't know if we take with the Knight
or not I don't like taking with the
Knight because then what I've done is
I've actually put myself in a pin now
which is rather embarrassing
but if Knight if White's clearly one
right there isn't it uh in if Knight
takes yeah yeah if Knight takes then I
would probably just sort of bring my
king up the board and just Usher my Pawn
to A8 so that that looks like an easy
one that looks completely winning Aman
we have some news as expected Ilan nnick
has clinched his game against Ray Robson
so I will bid you farewell for just a
moment we'll get our uh guest Ilan Nik
in the studio awesome awesome it'd be
good to go over that game with uh with
Ilia here as that's a that's a big
result for him and uh yeah like like you
were saying Ben taking uh taking a point
off Ray Robson who's um played on the
Olympic team previously and it's
definitely definitely very very strong
player but uh almost everyone is in this
field so it's uh it's crazy no no easy
points from anybody everybody over a
2600 rating in group a so we are going
to get him set up in here in just a
second but yeah and this this game uh I
think what was the move played is
actually King to
A6 and his idea is bringing the king
into B7 looking to take that pawn and uh
once he does once he does that I mean
it's actually Nicholas despite probably
winning uh winning a piece here who who
probably going to be going down his time
is taking down it's got just over a
minute and uh it's just very very hard
to um defend a position like this what's
going to be so annoying is let's imagine
King E6 gets played in order to meet
King B7 with King D6 because he wants to
defend this Pawn he's going to be
running into Bishop F4 check which is
something I alluded to earlier the idea
of this this discovered check to win The
Rook so if we imagine that doesn't
happen then here you know if we if we
take this uh this bishop we can take on
C7 and white is actually going to be uh
queening that pawn it looks like so yeah
that's that's what looks like in uh in
this game but uh for now let's let's
jump to the uh the game that Ilan isik
played against Ray Robson and we're nice
enough to have him joining us in the
studio IIA hi there welcome to the
broadcast thanks and uh obviously
congrats on the win today thank you very
much slightly unexpected result I would
say unexpected yeah we uh I mean you and
Ray have have played quite a bit I guess
right um and what from we were seeing
was a lot of draws a lot of draws
between you two so correct that's almost
the expected result yeah that's what I
expected for today too but um the game I
mean after after the kind of a boring
start and openings the game got really
excited right yeah so that's that's what
we felt as well so I mean we can start
at the beginning but maybe just take us
to the uh the interesting parts of the
game MH sure so I believe
the the game uh the game got really
interesting when I played uh F6 move
number 12 right so here this position I
mean I'm not I wasn't really very well
prepared for this game because Ray
usually doesn't play this line of of Pat
right uh but this position just is just
a a full symmetry so it's it wasn't
really that exciting to play but after
so after 9 D2 Bishop F5 I was pretty
confident that my position is is good
should so yeah so I just tried a bunch
of pieces and you know I don't I don't
see any reason why I should be worse
here unless yeah so here here's a moment
uh uh F6 uh after I played F6 um I
actually didn't realize that my that Ray
has the these ideas of playing Queen B3
or queen B5 right uh sacrificing his
piece and now and then I realized that
you know he he plays that if I take a
piece then he can take on B7 my Rook all
of a sudden is stuck right on A8 right
so um were you expecting like just the
Knight to move and then you realize
after ex yeah so the reason why actually
can you go back a little bit so the
reason why I played F6 is because I was
trying to to uh to get to develop my
knight on B8 and since I believe that
the ideal scare for my knight would be
on C6 right now play Knight C6 would
give me a weak Pawn if white simply
takes me C6 so I didn't want to I didn't
want this to happen even though this
position might still be all right for me
I I don't want to you know suffer yeah
unne to make myself suffer unnecessarily
so I decided to play F6 and and then to
my big surprise after thinking a a long
time right did eventually play Queen B3
yeah obviously if Knight F3 Knight C6 I
think I think I should be I should
actually here if Knight Knight F3 Knight
C6 here white has Queen B5 there's Queen
B5 right so I should I think I should
probably start with Queen D7 yeah and
then you want to and and then just KN C6
and I I said that my position is
perfectly fine so right coming back to
the game uh R did play Queen B3 which
was um it was it was important not to
play Queen B5 because you know I saw
that after Queen B5 so I can just do
what that what what I did in the game so
I took on E5 with a bishop oh sorry yeah
yeah Bishop takes E5 D takes E5 and here
importantly I have Queen D7 which I
didn't have in the actual game because
the queen was on B3 so um Queen D7 here
equalizes immediately in my opinion and
um I saw that and I was pretty happy but
then we played Queen B3 and then I
realized that oh I no longer have this
idea so now I have to look for something
else and here um obviously I have I had
an option of taking the Knight with a
pawn and and and and going into a very
complicated position or or so I thought
so Ray Ray said that he was actually
expecting me to do this so for example
if I take Ray will take on B7 here so
taking on D5 is a mistake now um to take
first on D taking on D5 first is a
mistake because I can just move my king
king h8 queen takes B7 and now I can now
my knet can actually escape to D7
protecting the rook and everything is
protected I'm up a piece up so the
difference is that what after what
happen after after what happens here
after Queen B7 now if Knight D7 then
Queen takes D5 check and he Forks my my
bishop and takes it and I end up being
down to pawns yeah so this was
definitely not a good option for me so
here yeah uh actually if we can go back
to that line once again after e f takes
E5 Queen B7 so here uh probably my my
only move and Ray also believes that
this is the only move here from Queen B6
so now the idea is that if white takes
on A8 right now I have Knight take
Knight C6 and I trap the queen so now is
the queen similar to the the game
exactly very similar to what happened in
the game but now I have I'm I have an
extra piece which gives me a winning
position right so instead of taking on
A8 here white should probably take on D5
with a check now King h8 and here I
think taking on E5 would be a mistake
because uh D takes E5 and I have Bishop
C5 and even though white does have three
pawns I have a very strong battery uh
attacking the F2 Pawn so Ray also agreed
with me and and we both you know we both
agreed that Rook ac1 would have probably
uh been a better alternative so after
Rook H1 the position is really
complicated I wasn't sure what exactly
what's happening so now yeah if Knight
D7 Rook C6 and I'm in big trouble so I
saw that I have to take on D4 with a
queen and and give up The Rook for a
bishop and so after Queen takes A8 Queen
D2 uh Queen takes A7 Queen takes B2 even
though I'm I mean probably material wise
this position is equal but white has
this very annoying pass Pawn on the a
file and I wasn't sure if if my position
here is okay or not because not only
does my opponent have this
uh dangerous Pawn but also my knight on
be is still stuck and cannot go anywhere
so you need some coordination right I I
I I I wasn't sure if I if I'll be able
to get my pieces together so that's why
I didn't I decided not to go for this
and instead I preferred the the one that
actually happened during the game right
yeah so here instead of taking was a
point I took was a bishop but you said
that maybe Ray was uh you asked him
after he was probably expecting F he
expecting and he was probably expecting
that position that we just talked about
where I have to pieces but he has fast
pawn and a rook right so here this was
the game yeah so here Bishop E5 and now
I I think he also had an option you know
he took on E5 pretty quickly but I think
he also had an option of taking on B7
here that's actually not a not a very
simple position because uh
um I I still I still have the same
issues but now the difference is that I
I I in many positions I can no longer
trap his screen because he has he has my
Bishop on E5 is hanging so for example
right now if I uh I can actually
transpose to to the position from the
game get the game we're playing yeah
playing Queen D7 so that's probably what
I would have done because at the very
least and this and the bishop would be
hanging yeah and then I have to take
with the pawn to make to create uh the
uh the um the connected pass pawns for
myself uh but here instead of instead of
trans trans trans EXC transposing to the
game right I I also calculated Bishop
takes H2 which which I thought was an
interesting alternative for me so now
King takes H2 Queen D6 then I just want
to I just want to develop my knight and
with a Tempo by playing Knight C6
attacking the D4 uh but here all of a
sudden white has Bishop F4 and I I think
I'm I'm I might be in a little trouble
here so G3 right and I I thought that
Queen H6 is probably the only move for
for me to not lose the Rook so King G2 G
or King G1 is probably another option so
King G King G2 Knight to R D7 and queen
D7 and all of a sudden my queen is
slightly misplaced my Pawn on D5 is kind
of weak and White's next move is
probably Rook a C1 and then the comes to
the
seventh seventh rank yeah it's not so
comfortable with the seventh uh the
seventh open as well as the D Pawn a
little B exactly so I thought that I
might be worse here and that's why I
would have probably transposed what
happened in the game
yeah yeah because the the the imbalance
that we got in the game was actually
quite interesting exactly and I was I
wasn't sure I mean my this this was not
my this wasn't my intention I was I
actually pretty scary you know to get an
imbalanced position after such a such a
you know such an easy easy open
opening I so that I'm completely fine
and and you know nothing's going to
happen but all of a sudden position
actually started getting I think I was
trying to figure out who was more
comfortable like who intended to get
here but maybe both were just after
after I played before I was like okay
I'm super comfortable now so I think
yeah so here you can go back to yeah if
if we can go forward to that moment so
Queen D7 was yeah this was probably the
IAL position honestly and I believe that
here I think it's I'm not going to I'm
not going to claim that this is equal
but I feel like if he ask the engine
it's going to say well it's completely
equal for both sides but do you have a
preference I think I think I mean the
thing is that after before I definitely
100% prefer black okay you know because
of what happened and R found himself
into big you know in in big trouble for
for the next 20 moves right but but if
why doesn't play before then I'm not so
sure because white white is White's plan
is pretty clear they want to create a
pass Pawn on the on the queen side but
probably probably Ray had to uh spend
some time preparing the the B4 A4 idea
somehow even though I wasn't quite sure
how how white can do that for example
white can try to start from to start
with rook
fc1 and uh now if I have if I play KN D4
white can move the Rook over to C5 and
and uh um you know try to double up on a
C file and then play a B4 B5 or or play
A4 B4 B5 right right away right so but
it feels like maybe a position where
it's almost easier to play with black
but maybe you have to be really precise
with the Rooks exactly so I feel like if
if if white does get to uh does get to
move their pawns and create a pass Pawn
on the queen side I feel I feel like
that would be a big issue for me so
maybe it's this uh it's this B4
just kind I think that B4 was crit not
not a critical mistake but it was a it
was a mistake definitely after which I I
suddenly realize that my position is
much better because well I I was able to
create a blockade using my net and my
queen on the Queen's side and white
can't really move after what happens so
I I immediately played Knight D4 because
I I saw I actually saw that b before
wasn't good and yeah pretty quickly you
just established Queen A4 and that's
that's annoying yeah actually here
uh I believe that Ray had a better
alternative to what he did so here he
played B5 B6 and decided to just try and
hold the position where he's probably
down slightly down a material right
because I have a queen and a pawn uh
against two Rooks yeah plus my knight is
very well positioned so I I believe that
he didn't have to give up his pawn and I
believe that he had yeah he had this
very tricky move Rook fc1 FC yeah so
here the point is that now if I take on
A2 then suddenly he has Bishop C3
and the threat he has two threats to
take on E5 and to play R B2 and I
unfortunately I cannot defend from both
threats so have to probably go into
position after D4 Rook B2 Queen A3 takes
takes so everything gets traded and I
believe this is probably a a a simple
draw maybe I I might even be the one
making a draw actually because Rook gets
to the seventh Rank and got to watch the
the if I can take couple pawns uh right
that's that that can that can get really
dangerous so maybe this Rook fc1 would
would have been a a better option for
him instead of instead of going to
position where he knows he's he doesn't
have any yeah he's fighting if I can go
back a little bit because I wasn't
actually going to go for for this so
after Rook fc1 yeah so after Rook fc1 I
was going to go for Knight A3 to move to
move my knight to C4 yeah that looks com
yeah so now I mean obviously now he can
try for Rook C8 check and and and and
then try to create some issues for me
but then my KN once again my knight does
get to C4 and and I saw that oh
well yeah as as you as you pointed out
the Rooks are separated the A2 Pawn is
hanging I'm probably going to be taking
move right so but but this is
interesting I'm not I'm not quite sure
so he can like go Bishop C3 and then try
for like F4 or something like that but I
should I should still be much better
here I believe it feels like it I mean
somehow White's coordination is is not
quite yeah but that's that was the main
issue of this position after before
white just can't get their pieces
together right and yeah as you mentioned
Ray went for B5 but pretty much after
this I think well his idea as you
mentioned was he just wants to get rid
of all the queenside pawns and just see
if he can hold but I mean that's that's
kind of asking a lot right um well I'm
not sure I think after my next move I
think he I probably gave him a chance
here because I I I believe that H6 is a
big waste of time honestly uh
unnecessary unnecessary yeah this is
this move is unnecessary I'm I'm kind of
uh preparing my King's Escape but that's
that's that's that's that that's not
going to probably not going to happen in
the near future so I think I I think I
should have probably gone for King F7
instead because King F7 the benefits of
King F7 are clear you're I'm trying to
bring my king closer to Center plus uh
there's no yeah there is no checkmating
ideas for white right now so I can I can
always play H6 but you know um save it
maybe right but if I don't have to play
H6 defending against the check mating
ideas maybe I don't I won't because you
know why why would I play H6 so you
maybe continue with King of7 and then
similarly play game right exactly with
without including H6 right into the
equation right so I believe that H6 is
at least an inaccuracy and EXA yeah so
after what happened in the game Ray
found a very nice uh defensive defensive
chance so after I played Queen C4 he
found Rook B7 which I believe is
probably the best yeah he's trying to
create some some ideas where maybe the
other Rook gets down right exactly and
he now as I play H6 now he can also take
on H6 and the same ideas but now
actually probably my H6 move even help
helped him a lot right because he has
some you know Bishop H6 sacrifices now
so yeah I play King King G8 and after
what happened in the game so Rook E7
Knight King H7 yeah so now the trick is
that he cannot take on E5 because I have
a fork after Queen D4 Rook to E2 and
queen D3 so I keep forking and now after
Queen D3 right the Knight is covering
all squares and I'm going to take his
piece so right uh taking was not
possible so he went he took some time
and just sort of did the same yeah so he
played H3 and here I think Knight D4 is
probably I'm not actually I'm not sure
so we we discuss this position after the
game a little bit and I'm not even sure
that um I'm winning here so after what
happened night D4 as he as he pointed
out this this could have been this could
might this might very well be a critical
mistake already but if he can go back
one move y here he had Bishop E3 instead
so we both Ray and I believe that this
was probably uh best the best move yeah
and I'm not even sure I'm not even sure
how how I can uh how I can make a
progress here so the idea that like if
the Rook gets down here and maybe trade
yeah the same the same idea but now this
the the point is that the E5 Pawn is
hanging because all you know during all
the previous moves it wasn't hanging
because I had I had U I had a fork I had
a fork tactic all the time but now I
don't because the bishop is protected so
um maybe maybe I maybe I can try for a
knight C6 we actually didn't discuss the
moovie we discussed after the game was
E4 but after E4 the thing is that white
can even just take on D4 and play the
other Rook on B7 and I I feel like I
even though I do have a pass Pawn on D5
I feel like it's not going to be enough
to win because the Rooks are always
going to be the Rooks they're always
going to be annoying as the G7 Pawn yeah
yes that's a good point um maybe instead
of E4 I can try for Knight C6 um I go
back a few moves yeah so Knight C6 here
and then uh and then and then play D4
right that looks more natural put
putting the pawns but then
again I believe that white just has way
too many counter play on the seven
strength so for example Rook maybe
something like Rook C7 D4 be to B7 will
work even though I'm not 100% sure and
now the idea is to just take on G7 and
go back and and always threaten the
Checkmate on the E
rank um for example like G to C7 yeah or
after checking to C7 yeah yeah I'm not
sure if if if you know if I can win this
maybe maybe I maybe engine will say that
I can but I no it doesn't look right
though yeah so during the game I
wouldn't be so sure anymore even so the
the the thing that really helped me out
was the fact that I was up a lot of time
on well you were you were up a lot of
time though also because position was
was hard him yeah after before race
started spending a lot of time on that
it's understandable because his position
was already um you know slightly at
least slightly worse I believe yeah
slightly worse and I guess he this is
maybe we you say the last I not not the
last I think there was one more point
during the game so here here I think
what happened was kind of forced yeah he
has to take and here this was another
interesting moment so here I had had a
choice and my choice was Queen takes F2
or Knight H4 mhm so the thing is that
after Queen takes F2 white will most
likely take on F5 and uh and I get into
this imbalanced end game where I have a
queen and a pawn versus a rook and a
bishop so um as Ray as I told Ray I
wasn't even sure that in case Fortress
Yeah so in case white does give up their
Bishop for the D- Pawn I wasn't sure if
white will not be able to create a
fortress as a rook so I wasn't even sure
that that I I can win that but Ray
claims that that position is is indeed
winning for black so I I I I believe I'm
100% his his end game knowledge much
better than mine but wouldn't you say
that Knight H4 was was just uh uh better
or uh I mean that the thing is that the
thing is that after this game Ray told
me that he wasn't going to give up the
bishop so he was he would be trying to
go for some Fortress with using the rook
and the bishop right instead of giving
the bishop up so um that's I mean I I
spent a lot of time thinking here so but
eventually I I did choose Knight H4
because here at least I have the the
clear way of of taking bunch of stuff
from White so yeah after this this I
thought this was very nice and it just
seems not quite not quite yeah because
there's an issue so soing G4 Queen G2
yeah ken4 would be a mistake here
because after Ken F4 have Queen H2 check
nice move and then Ken F5 Queen H3 so
basically a force white to go back but I
just get an extra Pawn on H3 so he what
he did was totally fine King H4 Queen
takes D2 and here obviously Rook G E7
lost on the spot because of to long
after what happened in the game sure but
the tricky move here is King G3 and G3
yeah so we we it a little bit after a
game I'm not I'm still not sure how I
win I didn't see the the force win for
myself here so the so the point is now
if I let's say check from C3 sure white
SK is going to go to F4 so King F4 uh
and it's going to keep running right to
E6 so now if Queen takes H3 now white
just going to take on D5 and I don't
think I can win this because White's
idea is very simple just double the
Rooks on the seven strength and take on
G7 and give up both Rooks for the queen
and that's just a a draw on Pawn end
game I mean draw draw end game where
have a The Rook Pawn right um so I
wasn't I wouldn't go for this for sure
so I saw that maybe I have have some
maybe I still have some tricks for
example like Queen C1 and now the trick
is that if here if King goes to F5 still
then I have then I do win by force by
playing Queen C2 that's the point now
King E6 is impossible because I have
Queen C6 and I win The Rook yeah so King
has to go back to the fourth Rank and
then I have a bunch of checks from from
from the second Rank and I'll eventually
sure take the Rook or the pawn and then
Yep this this should be winning but the
problem is that now if if if if I check
I check uh uh if I check from the first
rank here by playing Queen C1 the king
is not gonna go to F5 anymore but he is
just gonna go back to G3 and I I didn't
see how I can by force win anything
exactly so I also checked like let's say
this position is basically like the
same there the only difference that my
queen is on C1 but that that doesn't
really affect at least you have your
your dewn exactly you keep this guy
alive I would I would most likely I
would most likely have gone for Zana to
Queen C3 Queen F King F4 Queen D4 check
King F5 so now the whole point is that I
don't have a check from C2 so the king
can go can get to E6 safe you know
safely right so Queen F2 check King
E6 uh oh and then and then D4 and maybe
maybe I can win that maybe not so I
wasn't I wasn't quite sure but
definitely also true that the time
pressure yeah the time pressure was huge
in race so he he wasn't able to find
this King CH three and and so the game
ended right away after what happened
here it took so long surprisingly I I
win The Rook B four whatever do sure M
at this point you were just picking how
you wanted to win but uh that's true
like you were saying it was like a
completely symmetrical opening and then
it just blew up all of a sudden yeah all
of a sudden turned into one of the most
uh interesting games actually of the
round so um obviously coming off a win
here uh Ilan Nik congratulations and
obviously good luck for the the rest of
the rounds I hope to see you again thank
you very much Shan
thanks so that's uh Ilan Nik taking us
through pretty much all the variations
there in in his game against Ray Robson
and uh starting off the tournament with
uh with a win in the second round is
definitely definitely good one and a
half out of two for uh Ilia so far and
there remain a lot of games still going
on in the tournament but uh in the uh in
the a group we actually had a another
result that I can uh see here which was
Liang am against ariari and I'm not sure
it doesn't look like a repetition
necessarily but um there's definitely
the potential for repetition maybe with
with like a knight D5 move otherwise uh
it looks like tar did a good job um
again if that E5 tactic we were looking
at earlier doesn't doesn't actually work
then uh than I was saying I I did like
T's position if he can establish control
the dark squares um I was saying that I
did I did think he was doing well there
so it looks like that's what he had
actually managed to do and thean Liam
couldn't uh couldn't find a way through
and they actually uh did agree to to a
draw there so tari holds uh holds the
highest rated seed in the uh the
tournament leang Liam to uh to a draw
which with the black pieces here
definitely be happy with that result
yeah definitely we've had some results
here uh one of the surprises that before
we had Ilia come in we were looking at
Mista and theodoro in group b and we
were talking about that pin on the first
rank um it didn't really go how I
expected and now the engines are saying
0000 Z all the way through um the Rooks
were traded off and we get this where
did we leave it we left it around here
it was actually this move King A6 that
was
played
and black is is ready to make a beline
for Knight D6 and covering this Square
here and the problem is if you you know
waste all your time advancing that pawn
uh suddenly the black king is the one
who's actually maybe invading over here
or invading on the uh King side as well
so you have to be have to be a little
bit careful what actually happened was
he went and took A5 but here black
actually is uh is maintaining some some
control so for example something
like something like this maybe
uh could actually just hold the position
uh together because you can imagine if
A6 gets played that we just play Knight
takes A6 and then King takes C6 and then
suddenly black may actually be winning
um if we just run our King to the king's
side because White's King is cut off on
the a file here so yeah if you're not
going to play A6 maybe you just play
King B6 but I can advance my Pawn again
if I ever Advance the pawn you sacrifice
and then King takes here and black might
be winning by going to the king's side
so uh I think if both players just kind
of sit there in this position that uh
that might be a big save for for
theodoru and over in group a Vara koban
and Benjamin Vach this this game is uh
is pretty interesting to me there's
still a lot of material on the board and
there's a pretty strong looking Aon
there for Bach and just a second ago we
saw White's Rook uh completely committed
to holding up that pawn from any
progress down the board and I'm
interested to see uh the evaluation here
what's going on right um I can say just
off hand this looks like a very good
position for Bach um I don't even really
and I haven't counted the material yet
it's just if I look at this position I
know that uh that white just can't make
any progress here at the very best for
VAR is is going to be a draw if he can
salvage it here because this Pawn on A3
is worth like almost a piece at this
point
and uh there's no danger to Black's King
this Knight on E5 isn't making threats
um let's say even if we take the the
knights off the board pair of Rooks off
the board it's rook and Bishop and two
pawns for a queen which is more than
enough especially when you've got that
one all the way into A3 so uh this is
actually Benjamin box game to win
despite being down the queen I'd be
curious just I want to see how that
Queen actually disappeared from the
board here because it it looks like it
was intentional you know like you can
tell that that Bach gave up his Queen um
right to make this
happen yeah Bishop D4 yeah and and he's
comfortable here getting that pawn A3
and there's going to be a lot of
maneuvering ahead but uh I think both
players are are very aware that it's
it's most definitely black playing for
the win what's on top right now Ben is
maybe something like Knight B4 hitting
the Rook hitting A2 and just trying to
get that pawn one step further and let's
say in the worst case that you give away
uh let's say Rook for this Pawn and this
Knight then what's left is is basically
two Rooks and a pawn for the queen and a
lot of pressure on on F2 so it's just uh
I think it's completely in in Black's
favor here and dare I say maybe maybe
winning I I don't know if it's
necessarily by force but I have a strong
feeling that this position is winning
for black you think this grind could go
on for quite a while um it kind of
depends uh as I can see here both
players did just hit that um that time
control Mark so move 40 has been hit but
uh yeah I think this this could very
well go on for a while um but VAR is
going to have a not a very favorable
defensive task up ahead I know someone
earlier in the chat said where's Eric we
want Eric we want Eric now so we should
probably look at Eric's game it's a
little bit late I know uh but R kazm
shanov versus Eric Hansen group a um
does this were you whenever we jump to
Eric's game and you don't know the
position you don't know anything yet so
my heart races every
time um especially when uh you know from
the opening is actually Hansen playing a
Berlin um which is uh you know don't see
that every day it's nice to see some
cultured chess come out of Canada um for
a change was he playing for a draw oh
the Berlin is a is a winning opening
yeah Ben people win in the Berlin all
the time especially strong players so
why does it have such a bad rap then
well because it's just it's it's kind of
like if you try to beat it you lose so
it's just so annoying and otherwise if
you want to draw Berlin players like
okay I mean what are you proving okay
what are you proving so it's just one of
those annoying uh annoying openings um
so so solid you know when it's uh when
it's like one of the best by the books
and by test it's it's very very
frustrating um so yeah going forward in
this game it looks like uh CM janov
uh won a pawn but it's it's ever so
temporary and it is an H Pawn so um the
players have also hit move 40 and we we
do see km xov here uh going into the
think tank and he's probably deciding
because there's a few things here Ben if
if that Bishop takes the Knight for
example you have to wonder you know is
that Rook end game actually winning he's
got to think about that whether he wants
to try to avoid that at all costs also
the Knight is pinned to that pawn on B2
so it's not so easy to to try to gener
winning chances because the Rook is tied
to the Knight and the Knight is tied to
the the pawn on B2 and what's black
playing next Rook d8 is is a big threat
so uh it's actually really really tricky
position I I think this one is extremely
close to to just equality if not
complete equality so I wouldn't be
fooled completely by like oh extra Pawn
for white maybe he's totally playing for
the win uh I think black is is probably
holding this um especially now that I
see the hit time control I feel like
black has has good chances to to make a
draw here very good chances you
mentioned an option for Eric being
Bishop takes the Knight wouldn't that be
a devastating choice for Eric well I
don't think it would be devastating
because I always have this feeling that
The Rook end games are you know the very
least you you always have a chance to
draw Rook end games even down upon but
the reason I would say it's devastating
is is only because I I see much better
options in the fact in the sense that
this Knight is just pinned uh I I don't
think we have to do this but let's say
that the position were much different
different and these pawns are on A2 and
B3 where maybe they're not under attack
then I might be concerned about some
type of positions where white keeps the
Knight on the board and suddenly just
more pieces on the board more chances to
win but in this case uh I I agree with
you I I wouldn't take that night I'd
focus on on uh moves like Rook h8 just
hitting the pawn if King G2 Rook back to
G8 check try to force that King to the
side of the board if the King goes back
to F3 just Shuffle Rook h8 Rook G8 you
also have Rook d8 here hitting the
pinning it I think no matter what it is
uh just just a draw like I don't think
km janov has enough to to win this
position here Ben in our YouTube chat
Paul Google says the Berlin a fighting
opening LOL he says if you are fighting
for a draw with the Berlin you are doing
it wrong you just draw you just draw
sounds like he agrees it sounds like he
sounds like he has an experienced Berlin
player you know and and I'm telling you
benett this is one of the most annoying
openings in chess it's so solid but you
can win games with it as well it's like
when you get annoyed with it and you're
like man this guy's just playing for a
draw then you try to beat him nope you
lose that's what happens uh I don't
think we've mentioned earlier that
Dennis kri and Sergey Arenberg Drew
their game oh I understand we have a
result Eric Hansen and rustam have ended
their game is that yes yeah indeed and
this is a draw that makes total sense I
mean like I was saying in this position
position there there simply moves like
rook h8 and Rook G8 back and like you go
defend and then I check you are you
really going to put your king all the
way on the side of the board just to
defend that no because I mean there Rook
d8 winning a piece so really with the
the Knight pinned to a pawn here this H
pun is is meaningless and black has so
much counterplay with Rook h8 Rook d8
Rook G8 Jack uh I honestly think it's
just a dead dead draw so Ram looked like
he hit move 40 he spent time thinking he
was like is there anything here is there
anything here decided no dead draw and
uh and Eric um draws km shanov and
that's probably a bigger result for for
km janov because he lost his first round
game now a draw with the with the white
pieces here so he's off to a bit of a
rough start in in this tournament so far
same results thus far for Eric as well
yes um a loss in the first round and
then a draw in the second Mista and
theodoro have drawn in group b we now
know that group b is completely finished
up um and there is just one game going
in the entire field and it is a Ian and
B need to ask you though as far as
Eric's attitude goes I know you guys
stream uh later tonight is that correct
both of you will be streaming yeah we'll
probably uh I mean after after this game
you know after we're we're free uh then
we'll probably find time for a little
subscriber Sunday stream you know where
people that support our Channel we like
to to log on play some games against
them but yeah we'll probably both be be
streaming I know that everybody out
there who's watching probably knows but
if they don't know where can they catch
you yeah twitch
twitch.tv/ chess BR so over on the
twitch platform for for live streaming
and we have a channel there and we try
to stream pretty much every day but
obviously that's getting harder as as we
both cut commitments here in St Louis
but you know we still like to do it when
when it fits our schedule here so we're
probably going to find time to to beat
up on some subscribers uh later on it's
like No Holds Barred right like it's
good good time absolutely no it's a lot
of fun and uh it's I think it's actually
going right now we're just going to you
know C up and and do our part later so
we got some henchmen that are taking
care of people right now but but we'll
be in to to finish off oh that's that's
going to be very exciting to watch I'm
sure everybody out there will be joining
chess bras on
twitch.tv okay well shall we take a
gander uh before we wrap things up at
aan group a oh that was the one okay so
we were just on this game I don't think
anything's changed no that was the move
that was played last and uh essentially
my my verdict on this is is also um
visible on the clock as you can see VAR
is I mean Ben Benjamin's not even at the
board right he's he's played Knight D5
he knows it's a good move that was move
40 both players hit move 40 but VAR is
actually halfway almost halfway through
his his new time uh and he just can't
find a a move here I think Knight B4 is
an incredibly serious move A2 is coming
I mean make no mistake this is uh it
might take a while just for conversion
sake but I think this Simplicity of this
for Bach is off the charts like you you
have these these two Rooks that are
saying there's no issues for your own
King and it's just almost any trade of
pieces also beneficial for black because
even liquidating if white just has a
queen and black has like let's say a
bishop a rook and this Pawn down here is
completely winning for black as well so
I don't I don't see any way that white
can complicate things there's no
counterplay it's just can B convert it
properly and has played Queen A4 Queen
A4 stacking up on that pawn does it do
anything though well I mean one idea of
Queen A4 is let's say that uh the move
we that I was mentioning Knight before
before happens he's trying to play A2 uh
he might consider a move like Rook takes
here Rook takes taking here with the
idea that you know if you take my knight
I might take here uh but again make no
mistake this this position by just
bringing the Rooks down here taking this
Pawn is also winning so that's just even
in the best case scenario I just can't
see uh VAR pulling this off um but
Benjamin still has to prove it so maybe
that's an idea of Queen A4 is at Knight
before uh he could deal with things this
way but when you've got your most
powerful piece your queen uh watching
over one Pawn right from advancing
that's already a bad a bad sign a
babysitter yeah you don't want to you
don't need a babysitter who's uh who's
that powerful you know get a get a nice
high school kid give him a salary even
you don't want a bishop baby sitting and
it's just a big Pawn you know it's value
is completely completely worthless so
yeah no this this looks like Benyamin
should should win and uh what would that
mean for the uh for the standings
Benyamin came off a loss last round to
leang Leen right and uh VAR beat
ivanchuk last round so actually kind of
everyone Topsy Turvy uh Ray lost after
winning in round one so um I don't think
there's anyone is that correct there's
no one on two out of two right that's
correct uh in fact I think we have the
uh standings available or or at least
the results let's put them up on the
screen we have them for for group a
right uh and let's see how we stand
after two rounds out of nine have been
played well here's the result and uh as
you can see only one game left pending
Nik big day today for him uh with the
victory I mean it was the Nik show it
was here for the spring chess
classic
um I'm sorry do do we have uh
standings we do not have standings I
will tell you that we do have Liam Lee
Ilan nck and Arian tari sitting at one
and a half out of two right and uh
they're going to be at the top of the
leaderboard um no matter what happens in
this last game yeah that's and if benyan
wins I think that puts him and VAR both
at one so it does yes and here's Group B
we have the results here kaidanov we we
missed him today we're going to have to
talk to him some sometime during this
event because uh I mean you talk about a
legend in chess uh the stories this guy
could tell it'd be nice to hear from him
one of his game analyses and then Stein
Grimson with his victory before we even
knew it over sokin right who's uh
looking for that Grand Master Norm right
and uh I believe is he's actually 0 and
two uh so far so not the not the
intended uh start to his tournament
that's for sure yeah I really thought
before I knew San's uh situ I thought
he'd be a real dark dark horse in this
event and he might still be right might
still be but um you know I was like who
what is this FM doing rated 2530 and
then I realized a situation I asked him
I was like why are you skipping the IM
Norm seemingly because he has all the IM
Norms he could just he could get ask Fe
hey and they give him the title um and
he says well in in Russia it's actually
more common than around here evently and
and you told me that also in China uh
the Chinese players do that yeah I mean
when when you're so good when you have
such a high opinion of your chess I mean
in Canada we just we think we're
undeserving of every title that we might
get so as soon as we get one we
immediately claim it before it goes away
like Tim Horton roll up the the rim cup
so it's pretty important to to claim
those while he still can bend but over
there in Russia they got a GM titles on
the ground so he's uh he's not too
concerned right well we're having a good
time here in St Louis and we hope you
are too remember to keep joining us
every day there's no rest day at 3:30
p.m. central Time is when you can catch
our show but theame games begin at 1:00
p.m. Central 2 and 1 half hours earlier
right here at usest champs.com and the
YouTube channel um And subscribe while
you're there you know 206,000 it's not
enough we need
207,000 and thanks for helping us set an
alltime record for the seasonal classic
broadcast we do appreciate it so for the
entire world's greatest B Team Danny
machuka your technical director Isaac
shrz your audio and Graphics Man Tammy
Hyde is your streamer my name is Ben
Simon joined alongside the wonderful
beautiful talented Grandmaster Aman
Hamilton Hamilton who will be uh that's
a lot of superlatives is right right I I
was wondering if you're gon to keep
going yeah I'll come up with more
tomorrow tune in he'll have some more
right yeah streaming later tonight chess
BR on twitch.tv until tomorrow we say so
long from the show me
state this has been a presentation of
the St Louis chess
club
for